dans quelques minutes nous aurons
franchi la frontière et nous serons dans
l'espace aérien israélien
vous pourrez passer la soirée dans votre
famille un extrait de la série les
prisonniers qui sera présenté dès ce
soir sur ici art tv
une série qui tourne en israël c'est
aussi surtout j'allais dire la version
originale de la série américaine
homeland que plusieurs d'entre vous
adore home laine qui est déjà rendu à
trois saisons reportage
maxence bilodeau le ton menaçant la
série américaine
homeland c'est de l'adrénaline à l'état
pur
créé par les producteurs de 24 heures
chrono elle raconte l'histoire d'un
soldat américain libéré après huit ans
de captivité en irak
il est accueilli en héros à son retour
aux états unis mais est il vraiment
héros ou alors un trait être convertis à
la cause d'al qaïda un des créateurs
dont l'inde c'est l'israélien guidée au
raf
ce héros de guerre peut se transformer
en menaces après le 11 septembre
après la guerre d'irak par bush
ces semaines guidée au raf qui a écrit
et réalisé
seule la version originale dont l'inde
en israël et qui s'appelle ratuf en
hébreu qui veut dire enlever et qui est
devenu les prisonniers à issy art tv
rock dans les prisonniers ce n'est pas
un mais deux soldats qui rentrent chez
eux et ces deux militaires israéliens
ont passé 17 ans en captivité en syrie
les prisonniers c'est d'abord un drame
psychologique sur le difficile retour à
la vie normale
le fait d'avoir deux personnages
principaux permet justement de
développer plusieurs facettes de leur
histoire respective dans homeland au
contraire tout l'accent est mis sur le
suspense vt de match on a pris les deux
personnages et on les a rassemblés en un
seul personnage la raison principale
c'était faire plus de place à lenquête
on a vraiment insisté sur cette question
est-il un terroriste ou non
mais qu'on ne s'y méprenne pas dans les
prisonniers il ya aussi un très bon
suspense qu'on découvre sans en dire
plus dès le deuxième épisode
et at-il pas à sa diffusion en israël la
syrie est rapidement devenu numéro 1
c'était la première fois que l'on
mettait en scène à la télévision des
prisonniers après le retour de captivité
une fois que l'émission s'est lancé j'ai
eu des appels de téléphone d'anciens
prisonniers qui ont enfin trouvé le
courage d'en parler à leur famille et
tout d'un coup les enfants avaient le
courage aussi de poser des questions à
leurs pairs les prisonniers c'est la
télévision bien écrite bien réalisé bien
joué elle a aussi l'avantagé de nous
faire voir de la télé israélienne de
nous sortir de notre univers north
american sacré vu ici maxence bilodeau
radio canada envers lé